[Music]
I probably started as an origami
practitioner before anything because I
took up origami when I was six but in
high school I got interested in math and
science and and so I went to college and
studied Electrical Engineering and and
then applied physics but origami was
always a passion throughout that time
and in 2001 I decided to make origami my
full-time activity quit my job and
devoted myself almost entirely to paper
folding and origami right now I've got
work in the New York Museum of Modern
Art and the Peabody Essex Museum in
Salem Massachusetts and a pretty large
show about 40 pieces at the Indianapolis
Museum of Art most of my work is
representational and for that I'm
inspired by the natural world
I love wildlife I love the outdoors and
when I see animals in the outdoors I
inspired to come back and to try to
recreate that emotional impact with a
sheet of paper I use a lot of math in my
work and that's because what's possible
in origami is is defined by the
mathematical properties of a folded
sheet of paper so if you understand the
math you can use it to create a lot of
forms that you probably wouldn't have
discovered just by trial and error so
and math is much broader than then than
what you might think just as many most
people's thoughts of origami might be
cootie catchers and toys most people's
thoughts of math is arithmetic and
quadratic equations stuff they learned
in high school math is much broader than
that it's the study of shapes and
relationships and forms and information
and the aspects of math to come into
origami are often the math from this
much broader world about relationships
and shapes and forms
you